[Applause]
[ __ ] John welcome to you yeah thank
you for being here nice to be here
always I always forget what a big guy
you are almost as big as you Conan
that's right I could beat you senseless
what a nice way to start everything you
know but thank you for being here oh
it's great nice of you to come on the
program and you know someone actually
quoted something that you said today
about yourself to me oh so that was very
interesting they said that according to
you shamelessness is your best quality
do you believe that about yourself I
don't know is whether it's my best
quality it may be my worst quality but
at least it's my strongest quality right
right it comes in handy on 3rd Rock from
the Sun God knows you mean you're not
afraid to do anything to anything the
first season of 3rd rock I appeared
stark naked in the audience laughed for
five minutes sadly and what's sad is
this was not part of the show right were
you on the writing staff the first time
I did Saturday Night Live yes I was but
probably I think it was your first time
yeah way back I marched in and I said I
would do anything they threw at me I
almost dared them and I remember Franken
and Davis sort of exchanging a look
right they'd had this sketch that they'd
been saving for the right moment
you may remember it and it was the first
sketch in the show I played this cranky
man who snapped at his kids and his wife
and his secretary and his partner he was
off to this insurance physical or it
turned out he was going to a
proctologist who was Joey's a good
sketch area yeah yeah it was Jon Lovitz
mm-hm and he crabbed in his doctor too
buddy in this sketch I actually laid
down on at the table on my belly like
this and Jon Lovitz reached up my ass
and pulled out an enormous bug with my
face in close-up as a camera and lovest
said my god that's the biggest bug I've
ever seen up anybody's ass and all I
could think of is what have I done with
my life
I have a Tony but they did laughs so
well that's the important thing
I found it doesn't matter how many you
humiliate yourself as long as three
people laugh somewhere then you've not
done your job now did tell us about this
Carnegie Hall
you're debuting in Carnegie Hall yeah
singing singing children's songs that's
right yeah audience of children I'm
hoping do you remember the last time I
was on the show I sang children's songs
to your crew that's right
yeah we had the crew come out you
thanked and they made animal noises I
remember which is just more or less
typical of them yes I I am entertaining
children that was from my children's CD
and half the songs are great big band
arrangements right so uh I'm doing it
with the New York Pops a full-out
concert for kids and it's all sold out
now what's it like performing for kids
cuz we did a show once here on the
late-night program where we had just I
think was like six seven and eight year
old kids yeah in the audience and we did
our show and we actually had an
economist come on we had myron kandel
and it can explain economic mayhem and
the kids started chanting boring you had
the boring monster yeah and which is you
know terrible terrible for the morale
but how you deal with kids I mean I
think the way a lion-tamer deals with
lions you wimp
you just q monster you do there and
they're just keep their attention and
entertain them you cannot give them an
inch or they will run roughshod over you
as you know do you ever just start
screaming at them in the middle of the
show damn you I'm John Lithgow why is he
screaming I have a Tony they only laugh
at me that's nice the I was thinking
about you the other day because there's
this new movie out called topsy-turvy
uh-huh rich is about Gilbert and
Sullivan the famous song writing yeah a
team I'm probably the number one fan of
that film because I was in like five
Gilbert and Sullivan operettas when I
was in college is there something that
you did and you're a big Gilbert and
Sullivan fan yeah
yes and those are their notorious those
songs are notorious for being extremely
difficult to learn relative and they're
hard to learn but they stick maddeningly
to the inside of your brain for the rest
of your life
you tend to have Gilbert and Sullivan
attacks and now it's pleasant and the
problem with Gilbert & Sullivan is it's
much more fun to perform than actually
watch yes right right so this can be
it's fun for you but what's the most
challenging of the Gilbert & Sullivan
oh the Lord Chancellor's great patter
song the nightmare song you give us a
little sampling just for that I'm saying
saya tee I can see if you may choose any
language you choose to indulge in
without impropriety for your brain is on
fire the bedposts conspire of usual
slumber to plunder you first the
blanketing goes and uncovers your toes
and your sheets tips to me only from
under you then the counterpane tickles
you feel like mixed pickles so terribly
sharp it's the pricking and your heart
in your cross and your tumble and toss
till there's nothing clicks Q in the
ticking then the bed cause all creep to
the ground in the heap and you pick them
all up in a tangle next your pillow
resigns and politely declines that
remain at its usual angle well you'll
get some repose in the form of a doze
with hot eyeballs at hair stop
[Applause]
thank you I was toying with the idea of
just letting you go I'm quietly going to
commercial we come back an hour later
and you're red in the face it lasts
about 45 minutes really stay tuned folks
well third Rock from the Sun of course
is on Tuesday nights on NBC and you'll
be performing at Carnegie Hall tomorrow
at 2 o'clock p.m. that's gonna be very
exciting yeah hey thanks so much
[Applause]